hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the clinical implications
of high sensitive assays for HBS AG
presented by dr. claudia gali associate
medical director of infectious diseases
abba diagnostics i'm christy jewel of
lab rats and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational
webcast is presented by lab rats and
brought to you by Abbott Diagnostics to
learn more about our sponsor please
visit Abbott comm now let's get started
I would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the Africa question box and click
send we will answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on that support tab found at the
top-right of the presentation window or
use that ask a question box to let us
know you're experiencing a problem this
presentation is educational and best
offers continuing education credit
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
I now present today's speaker dr. cloud
yoga we associate medical director
infectious diseases avid Diagnostics for
a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr. gulley you may now begin your
presentation
this nice introduction welcome everyone
and thanks for joining today the purpose
of this seminar is to describe the main
features and potential clinical benefits
of the newly developed I sensitive assay
for the apparatus B surface antigen the
HBS stage in next qualitative assay
first I would like to point out that the
laboratory assays we shall deal with
today are not commercially available in
some countries including the USA
commercial availability is planned for
2020
so let's have a look at the webinar
outline we will have some
epidemiological briefs then we will deal
with the varieties be very structure
replication and natural history and then
we will dig into the HVAC gene next
qualitative assay and we will describe
the implication of the assays
characteristics and how we may use that
in occultation infections in
reactivations of HPV infection in
breakthrough infections and finally on
treatment and points
first of all let's have a glance that
the current epidemiology of HPV in
fashion
the huge Polaris Project beveled
myrdal's 420 countries to estimate the
global prevalence of HBS AG as a sign of
HPV infection in 2016 it was three point
nine percent corresponding to almost 300
million infections and around 1.8
million were in children aged less than
five years actually HPV vaccination has
reached butyl Adil's as 87 percent of
even the infants worldwide have received
the three days vaccination during the
first year of life
of busy factions around 29 millions only
or 10% has been actually diagnosed and
only 5% of individuals eligible for
treatment received antiviral therapy
so we are still a long way from a
successful rate of HPV diagnosis and
cure
now let's have a look at the nice
dababneh viridi as you see they are able
to infect a huge variety of species and
therefore should have originated several
thousand years ago on the bottom left
you see the genotype diversity of the
human virus that is also related to some
differences in the clinical course and
outcomes
by surprise McGee so a DNA virus HBV as
you see on the right side as a very
small genome compared to other avian and
mammalian viruses
the HVD genome organization is shown
here it's a partial double-stranded DNA
of about 3,200 nucleotides with four
open reading frames those are coding for
the correlated antigens the X antigen
the DNA polymerase and the surface
antigen or h vs AG
it is relevant to observe the usual a
between the polymerase and surface G's
that has implications on viral
variability
the replicative cycle of HPV is quite
complex this is a DNA virus so the
genome replication happens in the
nucleus of the infected cell where the
viral DNA is transported and then
converted into any feasible form and
mini chromosome constituted by Covenant
Li clear circular DNA called CC cDNA
piece serves as a transcription template
for all viral transcripts including a
3.5 kilobytes Precor RNA and a pre
genomic RNA the pgrn a the letter is the
template for reverse transcription and
translation on viral polymerase and core
proteins inside the capsid the
polymerase converts the PG RNA into DNA
through reverse transcription which is a
pretty unique feature of this virus
followed either by employment in the
endoplasmic reticulum for virial
secretion or reentry in the nucleus to
replenish the CC cDNA pool not only the
complete viral particles are actually
secreted from the cell but also a
variety or non-functional particles you
see on the top right of this slide all
of which are fully developed with HBS AG
this antigen is also secreted in excess
top center here and this overall
abundance makes it the election marker
for the diagnosis of an overt ongoing
HPV infection
the class
profile of a primaries between faction
from the early stages to resolution is
described here the rise in the ventral
fall of the three principal serological
markers gives us a dynamic overview of
the sequence of events that will
eventually lead to HBS eg clearance and
the onset of natural immunity then the
occult or latent HPV infection develops
and we shall detail about that in a few
minutes
not all HPV infection actually clear in
a percentage of cases ranging from up to
90% in newborns to less than 3% in
immunocompetent adults the infection
becomes chronic and may be diagnosed by
the persistence of circulating HBS AG
for more than six months after the onset
here we see the clinical diversity of a
chronic HBV infection with various
degrees of hepatic damage it shall be
remembered that the different stages
after the initial immune at oral phase
may vary in any given patient which
switches from active to inactive and
vice versa an active chronic hepatitis
may then evolve to liver cirrhosis and
to ever cellular carcinoma of which
unfortunately hbb is still the leading
cause
we have mentioned before the occult or
latent HPV infection that's called OB I
this status represents indeed the
natural evolution of all HPV infections
and is linked to the persistence in the
affected cells of the episomal CCC DNA
we have seen before as well as to HPV
DNA sequences integrated into the host
genome o bi has been initially defined
at an international consensus conference
held in 2008 and here we see the latest
definition stemming from a second
consensus conference held in October
2018 so definition is the presence of
replication competent HPV DNA if it's
almost APB covalently close the CCC DNA
we have seen before in the liver and or
HPV DNA in the blood of people would
test negative for the apparatus B
surface antigen by currently available
assays
you
what you see here is a schematic
comparison of overt and occult HPV
infection differences are seeing the
amounts of total viral DNA transcripts
proteins formation and secretion of
viruses and also in the immune response
because you see there is a dysfunctional
effector T cell population on the left
in a bird whereas in the occult that is
an efficient T cell memory coming over
you
as we have just seen the negativity for
HBS AG is the first key indicator of a
no bi then the diagnosis of OB I
realized heavily on HBS AG sensitivity
over the decades ABBA diagnosis has
progressively increased the
sensitivities of his SBHC gsa's after
the current HBS's GE qualitative to on
the archicad platform the upcoming HBIC
gene next qualitative assay allows to
detect about 5 milli units per ml of HB
s AG and is therefore 4 or 5 times more
sensitive than the current best-in-class
of course an increased sensitivity for
HBS AG shall not compromise specificity
and indeed the HVAC G next qualitative
assay guarantees a specificity that is
at least equivalent compared to the
current on market assay on the same
platform this outstanding combination of
sensitivity and specificity has been
made possible by combination of Si
design and instrument improvement
there are indeed different definitions
of sensitivity for HBS AG while the
analytical sensitivity has been just
described another key factor to be
considered is the robustness towards the
natural variability of the target HPV is
a highly variable virus for which as we
have seen before 10 different genotypes
have been described so far you are in
the department a type of diagnostics has
been carrying out extensive viral
surveillance the program started in 1994
here we see some key data from one of
the more than 125 research papers from
that program this paper describes the
HPV variants found in a field survey in
rural Cameroon as you can see not all in
the major genotype source also several
subtypes or recombinant forms have been
characterized and described as well as
berra mutations
over the years Abba Diagnostics
collaborated with whu-oh on the second
and third HVAC G standards and also on
the first WTO HBIC G genotype panel as
well as another HPV biomarkers those
collaborations along with the various
surveyors program are key in developing
screening and diagnostic asses whose
performance is not affected by very
variability this has been a mainstay for
Abbott R&D and guarantees constant
improvement over time as we see here the
first and the current version of the
about architects bacd assays were
already consistent in detecting the
different HPV genotypes and subtypes
not surprisingly the same robustness is
shown by the HVAC gene next qualitative
assay that due to the increased
sensitivity
yields a much higher signal regardless
of the viral target
genotype variability is not the only
hurdle for ETS eg assays as we have seen
before the HPV genome encompasses
several open reading frames and
significant mutations occur mainly in
the three areas indicated by red circles
so in gene C the most frequent is a stop
codon in position one eight nine six
that gives raise to the HB - which is
prevalent in genotype D and in chronic
infections linked into that genotype
then we may have gene-poor mutations
that are related to resistance to
treatment by nuclear site or nucleotide
analogs
finally we will have also the chance of
having Jean s mutation this may be
vaccine escape mutation and also due to
the overlap with the pool region
mutations link 820 viral resistance
Paul Abbott asses are designed to
minimize the impact of sequence
mutations in the HVAC G region in this
experiment several recombinant mutant
specimens in the second loop of HBS AG
have been diluted in order to generate
the signal of approximately
approximately 1.5 times the SI cut off
by the current market assay and then
test it in parallel by the HBIC gene
next and two other essays by different
manufacturers the HVAC gene acts
qualitative assay yielded a signal for
12 times higher compared to the current
and say on the same platform we may also
observe that a negative result was
obtained by the other end phase on
several samples
so these are the main features of the
answer now which benefits may we foresee
by the adoption of a more sensitive
assay for HBS AG the first scenario they
may occur to our mind is blood screening
on the top part of the lineage the
kinetics of HPV biomarkers over the
course of a primary result infection are
described the current window period for
HPV DNA detection is about two weeks and
HBS eg detection occurs on average
another couple of weeks later
accordingly the duration of HBS eg+ it
is shorter than HPV DNA positivity in
self resolving acute infection this of
course with the current assays what will
happen with a high sensitive one we'll
see that in a minute but it will also
like to point out what happens in the
late stages after years when an obeah
has been established and circulating HPV
DNA is occasionally detectable
both early detection and OB I have been
investigated by the HVAC gene a
qualitative compared with the app but
our cadet HVAC G qualitative to the next
as they should and increase detection of
Mathilde samples
since the positive the samples here are
positive for HPV DNA and negative for
all outdoor HPV biomarkers and 28 out of
77 or 36 24 percent were positive by the
next assay then on the OPI samples that
are positive for HPV DNA and entire core
and by HBC 11 out of 101 were detected
that corresponds roughly to 11 percent
so overall the increase of HBIC G
detection by the next qualitative essay
has been almost 22%
we may also mention that in the
circumvent series the early winter phase
have been reduced by an average of 4.1
days
you
as we have seen during an acute selves
resolving infection HP s e-g persist on
average for a couple of months the
analysis of the late samples from 12 sir
conversion panels has allowed to
determine the increased length of HBS eg
positivity by the HBS gene next assay
compared to the current about are given
a say a longer duration of HBS eg
positivity has been confirmed in 6 out
of 12 panels with the range of 13 to 74
days since ESG clearance is the classic
signs of recovery this will impact the
clinical management of acute hepatitis B
you
how frequent are called HPV infections
according to the latest consensus
conference subjects infected by HIV or
HCV people we inject drugs patients in
maintenance hemodialysis all have a
sustained rate of OB I ranging between
27 and 45 percent in chronic late stage
liver disease there is area higher up to
60% in epital cellular cancer and
patients undergoing liver
transplantation
so as we have seen there are some
benefits for sure of an increased deal
for HB s AG so in the new assay may
represent an additional tool for
optimizing risk assessment in a variety
of settings including certification of
HBV HCV co-infected patients undergoing
direct antek antiviral therapy
reactivation associated with immune
suppression and also in liver transplant
setting when the use of grasper and take
or positive donors or OPI donors is
relatively common
however obeah is not forever HPV is
forever so the state of suppression of
viral replication and gene expression
typical of the occult HPV status may be
discontinued leading to the development
of a typical apparatus be that often as
a severe and sometimes even fallen and
clinical course
therefore any patient
by receiving systemic Kimmy Radeon
immune therapies potentially at risk of
HPV reactivation and shall be tested at
least once for anti core
incidence is lower than in those with
chronic HBV infection an HPV
reactivation can occur in up to 40
percent of people with obyeye when
potent immunosuppressive therapies are
used
risk is high in excess of 10% in
patients receiving anti cd20 containing
regiments and Mahler ablative regiments
for a metal poetic stem cell
transplantation
so here we see a schematic
representation of an HPV reactivation in
an apparently naturally mutation the
muon sentai yes and then PI core is
progressively weakened until HPV
replication is not under control anymore
so viral reactivation starts with the
reappearance of HPV DNA followed by HBS
AG and eventually by liver cell damage
this is the a pathological reactivation
we will see in a second
these reactivation is triggered by the
t-cell response to viral antigens
antiviral treatment show
as early as possible especially severely
immunocompromised patients who may
experience as severe sometimes fulminant
hepatitis if patients are monitored the
only for alt levels the diagnosis would
be delayed the employee of NH PSEG and
saves increased sensitivity will allow
to detect the viral reactivation almost
at the same time as HPV DNA since the
ramped up of biological markers is quite
steep and then treatment may begin
earlier
pattern that has been recognized since a
few years as a so-called breakthrough
HPV infection here we see the four
monster logical pattern of one of those
cases occurring in a regular blood donor
in the US the initial observation showed
that positivity at low levels for HPV
DNA concurrent with anti-hbs levels that
are deemed as protective DNA picked
after a couple of months and then
decrease the roughly until negative
after three months a transient
positivity for HBS AG was observed in
concomitant with the HPV DNA peak and
lasted as long as that one secretly
anti-hbc antibodies have been detected
and the donor remains positive for both
anti-hbc and anti-hbs
a similar case has been recently
described also here the initial sample
was positive for HPV DNA and anti-hbs
both at low levels further testing has
been performed by the architect HB ICT
qualitative to the HVAC gene acts
qualitative and to other serological
assays as you see the prototype arkad
HB s e-g next qualitative provided the
earliest detection becoming positive at
day 51 so this is 43 to 46 days earlier
than the current HVAC GSA the bars above
the graph show the percentage of condoms
with HSC GD 1 for 4 n mutation
in breakthrough infections as well as in
the late stages of acute infection and
in HPV reactivations the complex is
between HBS AG and entire HBS hamper the
detection of the surface antigen the
increased sensitivity of the issue is
the estrogen next bullet ativ assay
allows to limit this phenomenon as we
see here three levels of native HBS AG
were combined with human anti-hbs to a
final concentration of 0.06 point eleven
and point twenty three international
units for ml of HB sh e
which is low but above the Linnet achill
threshold of current hvac GSA's the
anti-hbs levels range in this experience
from zero to 10,000 milli units per ml
which may be found in vexing
breakthrough infections any men in
affected vaccinees
on all axes except HVAC gene next
qualitative and the HP has
concentrations of ten to twenty five
million is rendered low levels of HP s
e-g undetectable with a high sensitivity
assay anti-hbs levels - and 250 to 400
times higher I'm needed to block the
detection of low level HP s AG
now let's deal briefly with treatment of
chronic HBV related liver disease we are
still in search of the ideal complete
here for HPV which is on the left part
of the slide that shall revert the
patient status to the one we see in
people that were never infected while a
partial fewer on the far right has been
the target for many years nowadays we
are aiming to a realistic or even
idealistic functional cure with enacting
and eventually no liver disease and
negativity for circulating HPV DNA in
hvs AG and subsequently a reduced risk
of developing episode cellular cancer
this is the current endpoint functional
cure characterized by sustained loss of
HBS AG weather without to a conversion
for antibodies and HPV DNA below the
limit of detection as emerge as the
newly suit after treatment endpoint
current HBS eg detection assays
typically have an LOD of point o2
international units per ml which
approximates 100 units per ml of HPV DNA
the 5 milli units per ml achieved by HBS
a genetically dated correspond to about
30 units of DNA hence a higher
sensitivity for h vs AG can help with a
safer interruption of treatment
the difference in reaching treatment
endpoints by a high sensitive HVAC GSA
I've already been demonstrated in a
first study 55 out 114 treated patients
with HVAC G zero clearance by an assay
with a 50 milli units per ml sensitivity
where positive for HVAC G by the high
sensitive assay with the range you see
on the right side of the slide the
clearance so then delayed by six to 24
months in 31 cases
similar results have been obtained by
the about our cadet HVAC G next
qualitative assays on the right side
here that detected 24 out of 48 or 50
percent of samples from 13 patients with
an apparent HVAC G lost by our cadet
HVAC G qualitative to
so what may we conclude from that first
of all each PSEG is still the landmark
for diagnose you manage maybe infection
then having HB s e-g assays with an
increased sensitivity shell enabled to
diagnose a higher number of averted
infections and lead to earlier treatment
and a better secondary and tertiary
prevention allowing nezer detection of
reactivations and breakthrough
infections
increase the safety of blood screening
reach more safely a key and point to
trade man
that's all for today thank you and then
Creasy them back to you for the
questions
of course an increased sensitivity for
HBS AG shall not compromise specificity
and indeed the HVAC G next qualitative
sa share the specificity at least
equivalent compared to the current on
market assay on the same immuno
chemistry planet Earth
these are standing combination of
sensitivity and specificity has been
made possible by combination of fancy
design and instrument improvement
okay then we have number 16 here
okay good
one of the longest okay may you may
whenever you're ready so slide 16 go
ahead
over the years about diagnosis
collaborated with whu-oh on the second
and third HBS's standards and on the
first whe Ohba cg genotype panel as well
as another HPV biomarkers those
collaborations along with the viral
surveillance program are key in
developing screening and diagnostic
assays whose performance is not affected
by viral variability this has been a
mainstay for Abbott R&D and leads to a
constant improvement over time as we see
here the first and the current version
of the old above architects PSEG assays
were already consistent in detecting the
different HPV Geno types and subtypes
not surprisingly the same robustness is
shown by the HVAC gene next qualitative
assay that due to the increased
sensitivity yields a much higher signal
regardless of the viral target
you
okay okay now
thank you dr. gulley for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of our
webinar now if you have a question you
would like to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we
will answer as many of your questions as
we have time for ok let's get started
our first question is dr. Kelly what
patient population do you expect to
benefit the most from the more sensitive
HDS AG assay and why also thank you this
is a very relevant question indeed my
opinion patients experiences and HPV
reactivation will derive substantial
benefit to our health as treatment may
be started earlier and with better
chances for success also the Technion
evert infection in obyeye cases will
represent the benefit since the clinical
diagnosis will be more accurate and the
spread of HPV infection may be limited
if you wish more in general I would
expect the HVAC gene next to improve
overall our diagnostic capabilities has
already happened in the past whenever
assets with enhance sensitivity has been
made available
thank you now from it data presented it
seems like the new assay can pick up
mutant strains much better than other
athletes tested what are some possible
risks of delayed or missed mutant
detection by the other assays
well indeed the risk of misdiagnosis of
HPV infection caused by a lack of
detection of mutant HB s e-g have been
well documented over the years either by
single his rappers as well as
well-structured meta-analysis in some
cases as false OB I may resolve from
these and the reactivation of huge
clinical significance may be missed as
it has been recently reported by the way
in the u.s. in a dialyzed patient as we
have seen before as a robustness towards
where of variability stems from
surveillance of viral strains that
reflects in assay design of course a
misdiagnosis can lead to individual to
infect others too so it's a public
health concern as well
you
thank you dr. Billy now if laboratories
use this HBS Agfa with increased
sensitivity why would they use to
confirm the assay result
but a confirmatory essay will be
available to help the borders confirm
the test result from the new high
sensitive assay
now we have some great questions coming
in and I'd like to go with this next one
we each come in several times is the new
essay free of biotin interference kind
of expected that one HB s e-g next
qualitative is not acceptable to biotin
interference it was tested up to three
thousand five hundred and 10 nanograms
per ml as with the recent clsi
guidelines
tactically so you mentioned global
surveillance efforts in one of your
slides can you share any recent
discoveries well yes actually
our global surveillance team has
recently identified and characterized
the third strain of HIV group and sub
pad l which allows the first formal
designation of a new HIV subtype since
2000 about HIV combo and say by the way
identified it
thank you dr. Glee now we have time for
just a few more questions but I do want
to remind our audience that those
questions that we do not have time to
get to today as those that come in
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by dr. Khalil via that contact
information you provided at the time of
registration okay our next question is
the new assay already available across
ab attrition
well as medical affairs I can only
comment that the HVAC gene a qualitative
essay is due for launch very soon and I
will recommend you to ask your local
salesperson to keep you informed thank
you and let's wrap with this final
question this new assay looks like a big
step forward in hepatitis B detection
which makes me wonder if you are
developing assays another biology field
along the same line for example maybe
have a tightest C maybe even HIV
a Belize commit to push the limits of
infectious disease diagnosis across our
core laboratory molecular and
point-of-care offerings all with the
goal of providing the best diagnostic
possible
thank you dr. gulley now give any final
comments for our audience
I'll edit that part okay thank you again
dr. cloudy Ofelia for your time today
and for your important research and we
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor Abba Diagnostics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
now before we go I would like to thank
our audience for joining us and for
their interesting questions again those
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by dr. Kelly
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on-demand and lab routes
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues so
if they have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thanks for
joining us hope to see you again soon
goodbye
we're clear very nice Christy there's
just just one question I wondered
whether we might be able to adjust the
response and that's the one about biotin
interference everything that Klaudia
said is correct but there's one piece of
really vital information that I think
we've missed and the answer and that's
actually that we don't use the
streptavidin biotin capture a
methodology so it can't be influenced
negatively by an biotin I think we need
to be making that clearer rather rather
than just talking about a level that
we've tested against it doesn't matter
what the level is it cannot be impacted
this is not the same urine biotin you
know I think there is over abundant
information over that do things really
that we need to reverse that again yeah
we do are good yeah we do I get
questions every week from the field and
they don't understand it so I know for a
fact our customers don't understand that
yeah that's really good I know I know I
would done so whatever I don't want to
mess things up if people are still
wondering about biotin after a couple of
years of papers recommendations on
whatsoever I would say that possibly in
general some of our colleagues are not
really using the material they have but
we can it's not right everybody I mean
are in it it's the fact that customers
don't understand it can do that's one
another was similar there's another
seminar on the specific point would be
of health is very friendly
and you're by the fact that you see this
this is why we confuse staff and
customers because we always give them
the value that we're not impacting at we
don't say we can't be impacted because
we don't use that capture methodology
and this is why they're confused which
makes me wonder I mean if they just use
the review that Gordon s wrote last year
and the last year it should be clear
great I agree there's no there's lots
and lots of pieces of information out
there but I guarantee people worried in
these specific fields I know you're not
absolutely focused on clinical biology I
would be more worried about the
differences in very very ability mutants
and so on because if people cannot
understand biotin that's even more
difficult to I would be satisfied if the
part about variability is understood
clearly and this could be one of the
goals if you wish even if we're speaking
in naming about clinical implications
well that's a clinical implication and
we do cover that we do alright I'd like
to I'd like to edit out I'd like to edit
out completely the biotin base then if
we can do that because it's responses
like those that are actually recording
this difficulties so if that's okay and
if that's feasible I think it might
actually help us more
yeah we can we pick out everything
because I'm I'm seeing what questions
are going in tenders from customers I'm
seeing questions from customers and then
we'll just refer in two levels because
they don't actually understand the basic
principle if that's okay with everybody
and this okay with you as well via Rhema
no problem
until nourishes in my side thank you
actually working with me on this one
okay thank you otherwise it's absolutely
awesome
klaudia really really appreciate
everything that you've done to prepare
for this costing measure I think we will
reuse fat also may use that internal as
well if needed so once it's done you
know it's at least a year
oh yeah absolutely that's the plan
that's why we need it that's where we
need to be as difficult through the
process as we are so that we've got on
demand version that we're allowed to use
as well as lab routes using so yeah got
make the most of your your valuable
input so thank you sorry are we
recording re-recording the question or
no I kind of got confused and I don't
think Klaudia want to so I am Olga I
would love I'd rather edit it because I
think it's adding to the confusion when
we always respond with a level yeah okay
understood if that's okay
all good on my end I'll do whatever you
guys want
perhaps perhaps you're a knight and we
can just chat over that and see if we
want to edit it out or not but I mean
yeah I know Barbara I'm definitely
taking taking your lead on how the field
will respond to it since you're even
closer to it every day so I'm definitely
with you there I obviously provided more
of a text textbook answer from yeah but
which is not as well people we want
always to get out so I'm definitely
would defer to you and how we want to
message that out so the code with your
goal with that and yeah that's um that's
added to town because it is it immersing
in order to edit it Lanice not so good
well in an ideal world it would be good
to rerecord it but Cody is not
comfortable with that and I don't want
to be overly pleased we will need to
have an approved text for doing that
yeah
if you want to change the answer to the
question when we need to have another
text for the answer and that works out
good
yeah and that won't be difficult because
the the response is already in all of
our approved materials so that stuff not
her it won't be discipline without just
leave this out
well we did if I were to put it in we
can always do a quick over the phone
recording you wouldn't have to login or
anything so and we have plenty of time
the webinar thought till December
so I'll get this all put together and
edited and then if we decide we want to
do something different um we could do a
quick five-minute phone call if we
needed to provide it or add some thanks
quickly think is that 10 minutes
possibly maximum - okay fantastic
Thank You Lily yes whenever you show -
so that Simona Christie that don't don't
edit anything on the bio turn up Oh
Oliver
well perhaps listen to it again as it is
but I do have concerns over okay and
then we'll try and decide how we best
manage it okay
alcohol would be Eon Skylar Christy
thank you of course so while we're on
the phone are we good is there anything
else we need to re-record I think the
presentation sounded amazing we'll do
those little quick edits for slide let's
see tomorrow are two slides 14 and 16
and then we can do the slide adjustments
later and barbeque can give me that
thank you cute questions slide we can
drop that in but I don't need it yet
prior to the edits we can add it in
after you decide any other edits thanks
so much all right
well thank you everyone I appreciate
your time and any questions you know how
to reach me
we do thank you and I look forward to
recording and we'll go over that and
just check that there's nothing that
we've missed along the way so thanks a
lot team and awesome job
talk soon okay thank you buddy
thank you have a good day okay okay
thank you bye bye
you